yes Tony is my son it it appears he was
murdered by a man named Jeffrey Dahmer
Shirley Hughes mother of Tony
Tony of Jeffrey dahm
ster the true crime series starring Evan
Peters which highlights the stories of
the 17 men and teenage boys murdered by
the serial killer sir we're under arrest
for the attempted murder
the man out there you have the right to
remain silent Tony a 31 year old death
and mute man was one of Dahmer's last
victims killed in 1991.
the deaf mute guy
I wanted to keep him with me
so I gave him a drink with the president
sleep
and I wanted to
see if I could think of a way to keep
him with me without actually you know
killing him in an interview with the
guardian Tony's mom Shirley joins the
many who are slamming the Ryan Murphy
dramatization
Shirley slams the show saying quote I
don't see how they can use our names and
put stuff out like that out there I
would like to say to Jeffrey Dahmer that
he don't know the pain the hurt the loss
and the mental state that he had put our
family in that's surely facing Dahmer in
court at his 1992 sentencing a moment
the series recreated word for word but I
just like to read a poem that
good friend of my son wrote it's
something that's not only difficult for
Shirley to relive but also the other
victims families too like Rita Isbell
sister of 19 year old Errol Lindsay my
name is Rita Isabel and I'm the oldest
sister of Errol Lindsay Jeff
whatever your name is Satan
I'm bad this is how you act when you are
out of control I don't want to ever see
my mother have to go through this again
never Jeffrey
you what
I know in an essay for Insider last
month Rita recalled how the Netflix
series brought back all the emotions I
was feeling back then she wrote that the
scene bothered me especially when I saw
myself when I saw my name come across
the screen and this lady saying verbatim
exactly what I said I knew I was sick or
evil or both
now I believe I was sick and it was so
jaw-dropping that it all really happened
that it felt important to try to tell
the story as authentically as we could
and you know you need to have certain
plot points because he did do these
things but you don't need to embellish
them erroll's cousin Eric Perry also
called out monster for re-traumatizing
him and his family I knew Jeffrey Dahmer
and several of his victims and Friends
of Dahmer's victims are coming forward
too in another Netflix project
conversations with a killer the Jeffrey
Dahmer tapes it saddens me every time I
think about any of those gentlemen but
with a different message why it's
important to honor their stories
they had a life that they loved
I think it's important to tell their
story
nobody deserves to die like that to this
day I don't know what started it and uh
the person to blame is sitting right
across from you that's the only person
not uh parents not Society not
pornography I mean those are just
excuses